How would you like to know if
you're a carrier for an inherited genetic disorder?
>> Or would you like to know if certain prescription
medications may have negative side effects that are specific to you.
>> Or maybe you just like to know
more information about your family relations and ancestry.
>> Or would you like to know if you're at
an increased chance of having negative health consequences later in life?
>> There are so many reasons why you might want to unlock the secrets of
your genome. And you don't even have to be rich or famous to find out.
>> And now we're not talking about sequencing a genome.
>> Right, sequencing would require a lot more effort. What
we're going to talk about in this lesson is looking at about
a million different positions in the genome that vary between individual
people. The SNVs which we learned about in the last lesson.
>> Right, the single nucleotide variant. Or the single letter changes.
>> That's right. In this lesson, we're going to learn how to unlock
the secrets of your genome. But first, what we want to know from you
is, do you even want to have your genome's information in the first place?